[Musique]
l'hémicycles du département a accueilli
la 37 édition du championnat régional
d'orthographe et la 19e du concours de
calcul rapide samedi 17 juin deux
épreuves organisées par le cédas en
partenariat avec le département
c'est une expérience enrichissante on a
besoin de savoir bien écrire qui peut
pas être c'est un code c'est comme le
code de la route si vous respectez pas
vous allez avoir des soucis en
orthographe c'est pareil si vous écrivez
n'importe comment comme vous le
comprenez ou quand vous l'entendez vous
comme vous pouvez croire que c'est comme
ça on risque d'avoir des types de tissus
aussi un concours pour maîtriser
l'écriture mais aussi une invitation à
la lecture cet après-midi il repartiront
avec des cadeaux et dans leur sacs il y
a des livres
indico électionnaires c'est vrai mais il
y a aussi des petits romans
il y a chaque opération à chaque
instrument du sédase nous avons une
distribution de livres
la dictée portée sur un texte extrait du
livre de Lysiane Bernadette Thomas
intitulé je veux ma place au soleil
ce livre je l'ai écrit en pensant aux
enfants j'étais prof au collège et je
rencontre très tout le temps et des
élèves qui dans ces élèves qui me
disaient madame j'ai pas réussi j'ai pas
eu diplôme et j'ai eu l'idée d'écrire
sur roman je veux ma place au soleil
pour dire aux jeunes qu'il y a toujours
une place pour chacun d'entre nous sur
la terre le texte qui a été pris
aujourd'hui concentre bien je trouve
toutes les
tous les points d'orthographe que l'on
voit du CM1 à la troisième
avec quelques bons des difficultés
grammaticales lexicales mais pas tant
que ça quand même le président du
Département Cyril melchoeur et la
conseillère départementale délégué à
l'éducation Sabrina chuna était présent
pour soutenir les participants
alors où nous avons donc les réseaux
sociaux internet qui accompagnent nos
jeunes de du matin au soir et bien il
faut quand même savoir écrire un mail
savoir un voyou envoyer un courrier
savoir rédiger un CV savoir rédiger une
une lettre de motivation même si l'oral
prend de plus en plus de place dans
notre dans notre vie quotidienne mais
nous avons besoin de d'enfants qui qui
savaient écrire et de citoyens qui
savaient écrire également
après la correction des copies les
meilleurs ont été récompensés en
orthographe et en calcul rapide des
récompenses dans chaque cycle de
l'enseignement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]